hey there all you hip-hop teeny boppers
it's me wonder Mike your hip hop music
Maven and I'm here to review the new
song morning by someone named post
Malone so get your face tattoos ready
and buckle up because here we go
[Music]
or lonely traveler please help us we
have to move the cube
the sun is
why they call it morning thought I'm
strong enough sovereign
[Music]
[Applause]
I go to Wally's and I spent a Maserati
worth at this place bought a bunch of
booze and I called up my friends quote
unquote friends and said hey you want to
go hang out I'll pay for everything it
turns out when you pay for everything
people want to hang out with you
me hey everybody there is friendship of
convenience you know you work with
somebody or your neighbor with somebody
and become friends there's a friendship
of you like doing the same sorts of
things together in this case maybe just
going out and getting belligerently
drunk give me
a bit and but then there's the
Friendship of the good which is the
highest form of friendship it's true
friendship where it's like you're two
people standing right next to each other
looking out at the same thing and where
the Friendship is for your edification
friendship makes both of you better and
you're both pursuing the good together
and you love one another in in as much
as you will to go to the other person
for their own sake and what post Malone
is saying here is yeah these all these
friends that I have they're they're fake
friends and their fake friends for a
very specific reason not just because
they're deceitful or stupid or whatever
because we don't have a real friendship
of the good we're just all engaged in
Vice together and it's making us all
miserable keep going
[Music]
put a pause here often people will say
well at night time you know I that's
when I get really sad that's you know in
the thing of Frank Sinatra in the wee
small hours of the morning and maybe the
first concept album in America and it is
talking about in that very late time you
know just before Dawn that's when he's
really all mopey and depressed but what
post Malone is saying here is no I it's
as I'm sobering up in in the actual
morning at when the sky is bright you
see in the video it's a big bright blue
Sunny Sky that's when I'm sad that's why
they call it morning
m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g I'm a sucker for a good
pun well most people are really happy at
dawn in the morning that's that's the
wonderful time you've made it through
the night and oh good it's always
darkest before the dawn and now it's
bright and we're all happy but it's not
happy if you're engaging in shameful
behaviors that you would rather have uh
disguised either by inebriation or by
Darkness for people who are doing bad
things that are shameful then there's
there's nothing scary or or more likely
to inspire sadness than the light but
people who are doing good things and who
want to continue to do more things they
they love the light so it's morning
involves morning if like post Malone you
find yourself in a very sorry State the
sorry state is not exterior it's
interior keep going
stumbling down the corridor came across
an Open Door throwing up is easy and who
put on the common dogs that's a nice
tile floor I wish I got to know you more
who am I talking to nobody take me I'm a
little too high paid a little too much
for the time of my life
everyone 's side even when I tell myself
that I don't want to Sovereign
I like the ridiculous imagery I threw my
bottle at the sky and I said God that's
a warning he's aware it's Preposterous
and we know this when we examine it
consciously but when we're in the throes
of Despair or intoxication or whatever
sometimes we really think that we have
some power some power to challenge God
to challenge the reality that God made
there are different kinds of drunks but
there are angry drunks who are just
always pissed off at the whole world and
they they look ridiculous ultimately
they're angry with God because they're
out of accord with reality and so their
behavior is absurd it's Out Of Tune keep
going
foreign
[Music]
there's a nice symmetry it opens up with
this huge block of ice and it's burning
it down down down down down you think
okay is he finally going to get rid of
it now he drops it he just makes it
small enough he puts it in a drink and
he doesn't he doesn't get out of it
there's no saccharine sentimental happy
ending here he's still in it and he just
refills that drink how often do we do
that by the Light of the morning we know
oh man this is bad what I was doing it's
bad my friends suck they're not even
real friends and what I'm doing isn't
making me happy and I'm being taken
advantage of and I'm taking advantage of
myself and I'm harming myself and oh
it's night time again okay fill up the
drink please okay give me give me give
me another one give me another one one
more I'm sure it'll be different this
time it's a good song I like that so I
mean I I don't listen to popular music
at all and I won't listen to this but if
I were in a club or a bar or something
and this came on which it easily could
it'll be a very popular song I have no
doubt
at least it's a song that
reminds people of virtue and reminds
people of the emptiness of just pursuing
a life of decadence and physical
pleasure and Central pleasure it's
pretty good
pretty good post Malone
I wish I got to know you more